foreign
[Music]
you guys sent us this cool Hello World
logo yeah you can see that this is a bed
of your uh hello world and Bloomberg
Rockets yeah because we we just sent you
like a 2d drawing yes exactly for our
hopes and dreams yeah yeah now we're
going to turn this model into sugar
welcome to Sugar lab where Kyle Von
hasslin and his team are looking to
shape sugar into Edible art
they do it with this homegrown first of
its kind machine send them a design and
they'll candify it as many times as
you'd like
I just realizing now this is like the
Jetsons
[Music]
super futuristic get food yeah
after the design is approved a quick
control P sends it over here
super proud of this this is the current
3D printer we designed and built it from
scratch you can see like it looks like a
kind of commercial kitchen equipment but
it also contains all of the processes
that we're familiar with with 3D
printing
[Music]
it manages this dry powder which is
starch and sugar and then we've got a
print head over here which moves across
and actually prints the object
we actually jet liquid water and alcohol
into the surface along with food dye and
by jetting just the right amount we
create this picture-perfect image of the
object of that cross section
yeah so these are the hello world
Rockets
foreign
I know it's just air but that's still
somehow exciting yeah
since reaching Peak hype a decade or so
ago 3D printers have found a solid niche
in manufacturing making shapes that are
too tricky for traditional methods
the technology has been used to print
wild High Cuisine Creations into squish
lab-grown meat cells into pleasing forms
the idea I confess does not exactly make
my mouth water and walking into sugar
lab I was skeptical
but that was before I met Chef Jonathan
and tried his tasting menu
[Music]
yeah so we have a nice assortment of
different things we have dealer's Choice
here I got some chocolate covered sushis
this is your classic skull Mr classic
shakes experience skull
okay it's sweet but it's not as sweet as
I kind of thought it was gonna be yeah
exactly yeah you know really like and
just sickening sweet but it's not it's
like more meringue-like and texture that
is what I was looking for it's like a
meringue
[Applause]
these look like Everlasting Gobstoppers
but they are not no they're not
Everlasting Gobstoppers they're never
lasting Gobstoppers very good yeah
that's very good I just want to put that
out there and it won't last forever if
you buy these so
oh it's cool you get the color and you
get the Fizz you'll be give it a little
stir okay yeah
is it safe to drink this much glitter
yeah yeah it's totally food safe edible
glitter but there was more we have a
strawberry covered chocolate and more
the cranberry Frankenstein one of our
90s Bonbon shelves matcha Buddha for you
hazy IPA ganache Bonbon glitter skull
their happy little pencil Bonbon we got
our fun Little Octopus my favorite boat
drink drops it Sparkles green tea bon
bons really good oh it's like a layer
upon layer of magical bits and pieces
and finally the 3D piece de resistance
[Music]
yeah this one I we made in ginger it's
kind of like more subtle too than you
would expect I mean it's just it's very
pure kind of the platonic form of of
Ginger but it's not exactly yeah I did
not ever think I would be eating a
rocket you should send this to space Oh
yeah I know people
[Music]
still a ginger rocket chip is just the
culinary start as long as something can
be dehydrated into powder this team can
print it so obviously you sell kind of
end things to businesses and consumers
but then you the ideas to sell these the
actual machines yeah
so these 3D printers can go into any
commercial kitchen in the US and even
across the globe and we're going to
start selling them this year okay like I
feel like this is every Michelin star
yeah he's gonna have one of these things
yeah yeah yeah we've done stories on
synthetic needs in the past like protein
grown in a yeah now I'm picturing it we
could absolutely Prince meat here that's
it's totally true you could make like a
chicken orange yeah yeah we've done some
weird mashups like that yeah the detail
and the color here means that we can
create something that maybe looks like a
lemon but tastes like uh dehydrated
pineapple or something
after scarfing this much sugar I may
need these guys to 3D print me a new
pancreas
I'm happy to report that the food of the
future is more delicious than you might
think
[Music]